so any coding project you have done I'm
almost certain that at some point you
have come across random
numbers however if you use the any of
the libraries and functionality you find
in a program language you most likely
have generated the so-called pseudo
random numbers Mike pound for this
channel made a video about lfsr which is
a way to generate sudo random numbers
the reason why these approaches are
called pseudo random numbers is because
they are not truly random numbers it's
basically computer algorithm that is
capable of returning a sequence of
numbers each time that you basically
call this
function with and the numbers that are
generated I have some statistical
guarantee it's not very different from
rolling a die when you roll a die die
each pH has an equal chance of coming up
assuming of course we using a fair die
now most algorithms generating random
numbers share the same following
principle they start from a number that
basically called seed which sets an
initial state of the random generator
then it performs some operations
manipulating the seed and then it
Returns the such generator random number
when that function is called again
basically takes the previous manipulated
seed and basically repeat the same
operations therefore any of this
approach is deterministic and that's why
it's better to refer to them as pseudo
random number generator in fact if you
generate more random numbers within your
program execution starting from the same
initial seed you always get the same
sequence of random numbers if you don't
believe in me try yourself and see what
happens even though many people think
that it might be silly that a random
number generator can be used to generate
the same sequence of numbers every time
sometimes it's actually very useful for
instance think about you're debugging
your program that generates random
numbers and you don't want to debug your
code waiting for a certain you know
exception or bug that depends on a
specific occurrence over random number
by using a fix seed you will always get
the same sequence of random numbers
making the execution of the program
deterministic and then the bug will
occur you probably know all of this
thing and for this reason it's now time
to go to the juicy staff can a computer
program generate truly random numbers
well we just seen that that cannot be
possible however can a computer and not
a computer program anymore generate a
random number the answer is yes to
simplify it very quickly software cannot
Hardware can there are extender devices
that does this for us however an x86
processor that is at most 10ish years
old can do that for you without the use
of any extra piece of Hardware this
means that any non relatively new new
Intel or MD processor is capable of
generating two random numbers this is
possible because the x86 machine code
has two instructions that allow us to do
that one is called aand and the other
one is called RDC both of them
implements functionality to Generate
random numbers within your own processor
in particular ERD Rand still
uses a pseudo random generator so we
haven't changed much so far however aird
seed is our true random number generator
how can we use and leverage everyd Rand
in a program well I will show you this
in C so now we go in a bit in a computer
and I show you that however I'm aware
that all the programming languages have
rappers to access this functionality so
for this video we will focus out to do
this and see and remember that is going
to work only on an x86 processor so
don't try on Rasberry Pi because it has
an arm processor so here I have prepared
a piece of code in C as I said I have a
main function that calls a function that
I made called get true random number
which get our result as a pointer so
here we got a pointer and then the
function also Returns the number of
failure we will go in the bit what it
means number of failures this function
over here the one I called the get to
random number it calls this function
underscore RDC 32 underscore step I know
that it's a very weird name for a
function this comes from this header
it's basically includes all the
intrinsic function of the x86 processors
so that's why it going to work in other
processors and and just to be brief
intrinsic functions are functions that
to us like in in a program appear to be
like a function like RDC the 32 but
internally inside the compiler are
treated differently and typically
different um assembly code is used and
in fact we will go into this in a bit
what happens here is that I call the
function I get the result and the
function returns a number which is one
if it was successful zero if not
successful what it means to be
successful so it's a piece of art it
should work anytime the fact is that
this random number generator doesn't
matter if the one with pseudo random
generator or this one the true random
number generator are done inside your
processor but there are still separate
secrety and it has its own clock in
particular I read the instructions of
Intel and they say that this piece of
Hardware within your computer this piece
of Hardware within your uh processor has
an clock of 800 MHz which is not related
to the clock of your computer is
something completely different so what
happens is like your processor makes a
request and then it has to wait until
the testest is satisfied but maybe your
processor doesn't want to wait and it
can move on so in that case it's a
failure so when you compile I'm using
here GCC which is one of the most I
suppose famous C compiler and I'm using
a flag called Dash
mrdc which allows to include all the
interesting function we need for this
code in particular the one to generate
the true random numbers now because the
code is not optimized to keep things
simple I add a-03 which will optimize
the code and the assembly will be very
short now and in fact aign four we will
see this RDC which is the assembly
function that is calling to generate two
random numbers and the result is put in
one of the register of the CPU then
there are other operations ready to what
we do which are not the focus of this
video we just need to focus that our
compiler is doing what we want
generating true random numbers so let's
have a look how it works this website is
called godbold which is very nice
website for seeing in action how a lot
of compilers and interpreter work so
here I'm using C which what we need so I
can add new executor from this and then
we will see that we are generating a
thousand random numbers here where very
lucky there's no failures all the times
is generating a random numbers so what
happens is like when it fails just to
retry again until you get a random
number Intel suggests that you should do
this up to 10 times because the
occurrence to have 10 failures in a row
it's very rare but believe me it can it
can still happen is that when the
process is busy or something it can be
either that or because your processor
has really
issues so it most of the times it just
because it's busy but if you see that
it's failing a lot of times it might be
an indicator that there's some issues
with your processor it doesn't mean that
it's doomed but still it's in fact here
uh I couldn't find an example of
um not like failures it's always zero
let's see what happens if I run again
nothing it's it's working is this a new
computer well I'm using the computer of
owner of this gold bolt so so I'm not
compiling on my computer who knows like
what could happen inside so the thing is
the following how useful is this like
it's very useful the answer is
no and so people might question why I'm
dying all this fast so generating true
random nums and then it's not useful
well depends useful for one it's not
useful to Generate random numbers within
your code because first all is low so
people have compared with sudo random
generators and statistically is lower
but let's assume that we have all the
times so you don't don't care about how
slow it is why it's not encouraged to
use because a true random number
generator has no statistical guarantee
of the nums that it generates that's why
it's called RDC oh do you mean as it
could come up with something like a I
don't know an even number or number one
they can
come it means that the sudo generators
um most of them are guaranteed that
every number have the have the same
probably to be drawn I see so we say
it's a uniform distribution here there's
no guarantee so you might have the same
number time after time you might have a
preference to a set of numbers like
towards so so we say that the
distribution is skewed it might be
skewed because we don't know what source
of entropy the processor is using can
you trap that or no is that no but the
reason why it's called air seed is the
secret why it's useful because you can
use it to generate a random number to be
used as a sid I have the same function
get to random number but this time I use
the true random number using Rd seed to
initialize the sud random generators
within C so I use the result to feed s
Rand that says the SE and then afterward
I have a for Loop that generates a
thousand of random numbers let's uh
execute this
add new executor from this and here we
go these are sudo random numbers
generated starting from a true random
number generator we can basically try
again to execute
this it's going to take a while and as
you can see all the numbers are
different so they're pseudo random
randomly seated it's a pseudo random
number generator initialized with a true
random
number you can see that it's has changed
and it's going to change again it's
going to change again and let's see how
it goes so the next state we're going to
shift one to the right so one uh 1 0 and
then thing is am I going to pass it
integers strings I can do all of the
above let's just check that I'm not
lying because I do sometimes